uh and we're going to do a minute a
speaker given the fact that we have so
many speakers and I want to make sure we
get to every single speaker uh my name
is sh FAL and I am here as a resource
regarding the landmarks issue in respect
to 45 Park Place thank you very
much
day than
sir your time will begin again and you
will have a
minute conservatives from across the
country who do not live in this great
and diverse City have spoken against
this project in the name of American
nationalism yet it is utterly
hypocritical of their otherwise limited
government stance to tell a private
landlord what to do with his property is
absurd the irony of their intolerance is
s if it was a
church if it was a church being built
and people were trying to prevent its
construction though these same
conservatives would be calling a
socialist takeover from an overreaching
government to the world this country
stands as a beacon of Freedom even with
our Litany of fals when the Nazis
dominated Europe they burn synagogues to
the ground Muslim countries that are
often criticized for their over
have places of buried worship
Afghanistan Egypt Iraq Lebanon and even
Iran have synagogues Islam did not
commit the atrocities on September 11th
it was a radical step tyrannical and
absolutist in their means much like
those who battled the Crusades in the
Holocaust that wounded our country on
911 Society can only benefit from the F
understanding of the
[Applause]
culture
oname
on on shame
on on
[Music]
you okay let me just say that we don't
get need too quiet down over there let
me just say that if you interrupt the
speaker I have to give them another
minute we are adhering to Robert's Rules
of Order you were not interrupted when
you speak so please please do not
interrupt the speakers our next speaker
is Paul new followed by Stuart cofman
and let me just say a thank you to Paul
who has been extremely involved along
with Yeta in leading the fight has
always thrived as a as a community of
Tolerance and that as much as people
care deeply about this issue in America
we do not tell our neighbors where they
may and may not pray and I encourage
this board to stay firm
in Thank you
very next speaker is steuart Kaufman
followed by
Louis 45 the hospital I'm Stuart cman of
the alliance for Interfaith resistance
um I listened to Senator Squadron say
that he was reminding folks of what we
suffered down here and is
important the fact is that the community
board needs to remember what happened
down here and that it
is I that Mr alal who introduced himself
as a resource and who was in fact one of
the owners of the property was before
when that Mrs Boland was talking about
her son was laughing with his lawyer
which I think is metaphoric for the
entire way that Islam approaches the
West one thing I want to talk to the
community about a couple of weeks ago
one of the mayor's assistants wired the
senator Governor Palin and said that she
should mind her own business well I will
tell you that this is not just a local
issue this is not a New York issue it
was America that was attack
on
americ every one other thing and one I
believe I remind what Mr Justice Jackson
said the Constitution is not a suicide
Act
Follow
[Applause]
by my name is Luis deatra I was a member
of the New York Board of Trade on 911 I
was late that morning and when the first
flame hit I was just putting on my shoes
I lived 5 minutes away across the Hudson
River in Jersey City I opened the blinds
and saw the flames shooting out and then
I watched as a second plane plowed the
South Tower in that south tower four of
my fellow members and a couple of my
friends were having a breakfast meeting
at maril Lynch up on the top floor
another buddy of mine a tennis player
that I played with Dave bow formerly
with the New York Giants Bond Trader
with caner Fitzgerald was in his office
they all died on that day now if as
these politicians say this is an
Outreach I would welcome an out reach
from the Arab Community let them allow a
synagogue to be built in Riyad let them
allow a cic church and a Christian
Church to be allowed to be built in
Medina they will not allow that this is
an affront to every American a blasphemy
and a
[Applause]
disgrace is BR Joseph by h
r my name is Brett Joy I'm an attorney
here on behalf of the American Center
for Law and Justice and we represent Tim
Brown who is a firefighter and first
responder who lost nearly 100 friends in
September 11th and witness firsthand the
horrors of that day first let me say
first off this has nothing to do with
religious freedom this is about land use
and proper procedure there are
approximately 22,000 buildings
landmarked in New York City of which
over a thousand are landmarked solely on
the basis of historical importance alone
including a building that was bombed by
the terrorist group Weather Underground
so for the landmarks uh commission or
this board to suddenly be concerned
about the unfettered property rights of
property owners WS of an abuse of
discretion second it is hard to imagine
that this property would not be Landmark
but for its proposed use as a mosque and
for you guys to take that into
consideration or the landmarks
commission is also improper and if it's
not Landmark we intend to challenge that
decision as we believe that improper
political considerations have come into
play here including your inappropriately
decision earlier this summer to endorse
the proposed use the proposed mosque
prior to a vote on the landmarks issue
now let me wrap up by saying this
tolerance ladies and gentlemen is
nothing more let me just finish this
sentence tolerance is nothing more than
a buzzword that can be used to justify
any Behavior good or bad and today I'm
proud to stand with New Yorkers and
Americans sir you're out of time we will
not be DED into remaining silent false
promise of Tolerance at all
[Applause]
father hi nette Raymond Rivera tolerance
is a crime when applied to evil Islam is
not a religion it is an ideology made up
of banking Finance medicine and
Jan
Bloomberg Mayor Bloomberg needs to learn
what the First Amendment really means it
doesn't mean freedom of religion it
means tolerance and Samuel Adams said we
are not tolerant of any government that
would try to usurp our
government
am I
B bir want us to wear a burka simply
because you can't smoke a cigarette
throw up
our David C followed by Matthew
April my name David C from the fiscal
policy Institute um I spent 6 years
right after September 11th coordinating
the labor community the I Network to
rebuild New York and I invest a lot of
my life in seeing that New York was
rebuilt properly and I feel very
strongly about it this issue has drawn
me back in I'm very upset to see the
kind of reaction that we're getting from
uh the proposal to have a cent of was in
any way connected with you know I am my
family is Jewish I grew
up my family is Jewish um I'm not very
religious I spend a lot of time at the
92nd Street Y which is a fantastic FC
place that feels like it's really
representing the Jewish cultural
tradition without necessarily you know
while also welcoming people who are from
other religions as well as people who
are Jewish and not to can find a home
there I think it was very appealing to
me to hear a center that was being
modeled on that in some way um and I
think it's important to remember that
there were Muslims living in in the
lower Manhattan Community before
September 11th and working here there
were Muslims who were killed on
September 11th ask died who were working
very strongly with me in the rebuilding
and I just think it's very important to
figure out how to build us together
thank
you
mat John Castellano followed by cherra
Rose hello every good evening everyone
my name is John klinov I'm a longtime
resident of New York City I live in
shant town I did spend nine months down
at Ground Zero in the recovery effort so
I think I've seen a little bit of a
little bit of what's going on and what I
don't understand about the Muslim
Community right now if they're coming to
us and telling us we need some tolerance
of them why couldn't they have come to
community board one and said to
community board one listen we're
planning on putting a mque in this area
if you think it's a sensitive issue
maybe we should have a couple of
hearings see how the community feels
about it and maybe move it out of a
perimeter of or an acceptable area away
from Ground Zero now I don't see this I
also don't understand how when we're
looking at a at a group of people the
Muslim religion and their war cry their
war cry frightens if you ever listen to
the the tapes of Flight 93 one of the
last things you hear is
allahar as our people are dying in that
plane as our people dying in the World
Trade Center this was their war cry I
don't understand how we're not saying
don't build it but move it away from us
give us a little
debr I guess that's it I just
like realiz
pain let's not forget the walk Rose
followed by
[Applause]
Larry hi there uh supporters of the
kadoba initiative would say this is a
great way to strengthen Muslim and West
relations by showing acceptance and
tolerance for Muslim American people
they may also say people in opposition
are racist bigots religiously intolerant
or trampling on the First Amendment
amendment I would say to them the first
amendment is not only there to give us
rights to freedom of religion but to
freedom of speech and
petition We the People disapprove of the
13 story Moss overlooking the crater
that
is our disapprovement has nothing to do
with religion and everything to do with
respect it is insulting to us as
Americans and anyone who has read the
Quran knows that to supporters who say
non-supporters are islamophobes or
intolerant of Islam personally how do
you expect me to be tolerant when I
watch my female counterparts walking
around in 100 Dee and Buras or in the
crazy people who believed in your peace
loving God tried to destroy the Twin
Towers twice when did we become so
politically correct that we can't see
what's right in front of
[Music]
usar followed by
Frank my name is Larry sinkin I am the
proud father of 21 years old Vladimir
sinkin also present
here hundreds of family members and
Friends of September 11 victims from
Brooklyn Queens United all together into
the organization called September 11
family
group um I would like to remind you that
on September 11 2001 we had a few groups
of people dancing thinking singing and
celebrating the
victory now we have another group of
people and in one minute I would like to
ask you if you see any big difference
between
them I'm addressing the Imam R and his
supporters including those community
members who voted for the
mask what is so special in that place
for them it's obviously I'm going to ask
you to wrap up
please obviously
secret place for us what is so special
in that place for them they are trying
to prove their tolerance last sentence
their
tolerance and they prove their un
toolerance because they oppose our
protess okay Frank Mor Follow
by good evening everyone how are you
today great okay I represent uh notes to
the mosc groundzero on Facebook and I
just wanted to say I heard everybody's
opinion I loved it but what what would
the dead people say the innocent people
that died in the World Trade Center the
police officers the firefighters that
died what did they say we are tired of
hearing Allah abbar even from two blocks
away I also seen act 17 in the audience
that praise
Jesus well they they were oppressed by
Muslims in Dearborn Michigan we need to
show them their
[Applause]
[Music]
support good evening uh my name is Susan
con and I'm a candidate for congress
here in the E District The District in
which uh the proposed mosque will be
situated uh however I'm speaking to this
evening uh as a fellow New Yorker a
fellow American and a fellow human being
on September 11th
2011 our nation suffered the worst
attack that our homeland in our history
our enemies Muslim extremists engaged in
the barbaric Act of flying commercial
airliners into the Twin Towers
intentionally causing the horrific
deaths of nearly 3,000 innocent men
women and children of all faiths and
denominations simultaneous attempt were
made to perpetrate similar accept here
on our nation's capital there's not a
person in this District in this city in
this or in this country that was not
forever impacted by this atrocious Act
of
cowardice we cannot bring the victims
back we cannot alleviate the great
anguish of those that survive them okay
ma'am you're what we can and must do is
respect the feelings of the families of
the victims who are speaking out against
this proposal your time is up please our
last speaker is Stella
[Applause]
Martinez the man says that he is a man
of peace that what he would like to do
is maybe bring some kind of unity into
us so we appeal to him to the board to
our mayor to everyone that says it's
okay for this mask you have said you
have known the pain that is causing to
build this musk you have seen the
division that is causing in our city the
best thing to do that the IM can do as a
man of Peace as an intelligent man that
he is supposed to be is to say no we
understand the pain that is causing the
people that lost many friends many
family members I fire man not
believe to say to the people of America
to say to the people of York we will not
build its must we understand how painful
it is to
[Applause]
you we're now in the business session
you have the minut attach is there a
motion to move the minutes is there a
second all in
favor
from a technical point of view the
committee was very United on it and I
think in all the years we've looked at
all this stuff I feel very comfortable
that as an individual Landmark it
doesn't meet the order it is
contributing if it was in the historic
district that I wanted to be 10 years
ago but it
didn't I I just want to comment that
some woman in the audience who's not on
the committee board sto anyone those
outsid and said I just wanted to know
that me an hour to read this resolution
carefully and I just thought it was a
brilant brilliant complicated resolution
I'm saying that for all of the community
board that yes some of it is black and
some of it is white and some of it is
gray and I I the rhythm of the
resolution I would I would posit leads
to a logical conclusion but it's not all
dactic as for the
faade that is unusual that we suggested
that the facade be stored but that's
because doesn't rise to individual
Landmark status but I think we did go
that extra step to try to be sensitive
to other issues that normally should not
be a part of this discussion
furthermore furthermore I would add that
we did more research on this building on
this matter than ever before in Roger
and my term on the Larks I bought the
AIA guide I bought we bought the um the
brand new uh the brand new um wsky guy
to New York City we used so many
different sources it took hours to write
this one resolution so so just be it
known that we went the extra money I
joke let me ask you this just h of why
if they save the front and put it up
somewhere else would that be still
valuable uh we we've dealt with that on
Pearl Street uh the rock Ro development
uh you supported as Jo say it could be
moved um Alan Solomon has spent years
trying to save the facade of the Colgate
Building look at it I wor Parts every
day of my life and I The Rock R haven't
done a great job there we're trying to
do something better than that so we
don't want it in some Museum we want it
actually we you know to argue in favor
of it being landmarked although I would
prer to you guys on this but what I my
the Bas of my question is once you if
you say it's not going to be Landmark
then what Authority you have left to ask
anything of them in terms of saving any
part of the structure well we put it in
the resolution we' like we like LPC to
support our position of having the
facade kep on but once LPC votes against
landmarking isn't their Authority
effectively finished completely we we
can say tonight we want it landmarked
LPC whenever it says can can not take
our advice as you know but what do you
want LPC to say uh what we've said here
is that we don't believe it meets
individual l Mar State it is a build it
is a it would be a contributing building
in a historic district but it's not in a
historic district but we would like LPC
to consider uh keeping the facade uh on
site under what Authority excuse me
under what Authority if they're not
Landmark they we know you know what the
process is LPC with staff can say to the
owner we would like you to do this and
the owners typically listen in my all
right I mean Michel there there's an
example president a lot of C IR thead
were were preserved uh when the area was
clear um Chef
Silverman cyos no Skidmore yes Skinner
yes s tanon bomb no Townley Fano no
Williams wi
bush
Okay J yes yeah sorry I I can't see past
the second row so I really apologize yes
all right yes um okay well let's move on
while we're telling the vote the second
um resolution is fairly straightforward
40 over we didn't have the samples so we
will amend the last whereas say that
stucko will be finished in color uh and
and will will the stuer will have a
correct finish and color um so we can
amend that and in which case we would
approve um that uh application
and the last one I suggest we take both
of them together is 406 Broadway and as
you can see uh we didn't really feel we
had enough information there so it was a
partial approval which um is suggesting
that if there is Danger on the rear wall
the LPC consider that application part
as a separate application and that they
come back to us with a more substantive
um issues I want to State quickly Roger
that Cory sharet was kind enough to
write this resolution
obviously the
bottom so if I can take both of those
together with the amendments to 4 all in
favor any oppos any exensions everyone
have you read the two res the
characterization and if you read any
Progressive uh person who has written on
this you will find that the
mischaracterization quote is a
mischaracterization this requires this
bill
requires police officers who perceive
that a crime may be committed and being
an illegal immigrant is itself a crime
these people must be CED does that sound
a little bit like apartheid or or civil
rights South Prior okay in the interest
in the interest of time this these
issues I I feel people have enough
information on I appreciate what Jeff is
saying but I I really disagree and I
think that this board should take a
position on both of these we can vote
against are we going to continue the
question
Anthony U I looked at it very purely the
scope of the community board land use
budget Service delivery issues if the
burough board wants us to take a
position on it I feel it's beyond our
scope I would urge people as I'm going
to do we're constantly going outside of
the city Charter all the time if we
limited just to what the city Charter
says we wouldn't do 90% of the successes
that this board has had so I strong
disagree with that sorry j I also have
to say that I had the same issues my
first questions were your questions Liz
brought it up also and at the end of our
discussion my personal feeling is that I
was taking a moral stand by voting in
favor of this
thank Michael I I agree with that
completely I agree Julie that we should
vote on it well
so just is the mar we can't we can't
make any amendments right understand we
can inate because if you read the law I
read the law as well uh according to
Arizona law you have to be stop for a
crime first before they can ask for your
um for your uh status now the federal
law
says the power of the officer just needs
the power of observation and sit
situational awareness situational
awareness that's it so why are we
condemning Arizona's law and not the
federal law which has the lower standing
to act so Mark we're going to vote this
up or down you can abstain you can vote
Yes No that that's a beauty the
community board okay I know there a lot
of hands there's been a call to question
we're going to vote on it all in I'm
sorry we're voting on with that addition
I suest something yeah we could exactly
I'm happy to take that back I can't
imagine that that that's not a sub
change I can't imagine that that would
be difficult to
get all right so we're going to vote on
the first one which is number four the
New York State marriage equality Bill
okay all those in
favor uh any all those
opposed one one any
extensions 1 2 3 4
uh
okay and then we're going to take the
second one which is on uh Arizona's new
immigration
law okay on Arizona's new immigration
law all in
favor
anyone one anyone
abstaining uh
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10 uh that's
it